on
la cité de l'emploi c'est ni plus ni
moins qu'une méthode c'est pas un énième
dispositif c'est pas une énième mesure
c'est tout simplement une méthode qui va
faire converger tous les dispositifs
toutes les mesures de l'emploi vers les
publics qui sont tout simplement ciblées
et ça effectivement c'est assez nouveau
et c'est l'objectif de la cité d'emplois
[Musique]
c'est une logique de coordination
d'amplification d'optimisation des
dispositifs qui sont destinés à des
publics plus tôt qu pv et de manière à
rendre plus efficient l'ensemble des
actions qui sont menées sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
il ya beaucoup d'acteurs de l'emploi
alors on a essayé d'intégrer tout le
monde bien sûr mais il faut vraiment
voir ça comme une opération de
simplification
[Musique]